welcome aboard the newest shiniest
swankiest research vessel in the United
States to Sally Ride named after the
first American woman in space this 238
foot ship will take Oceanic science into
a new era of high-tech exploration so
let's take a tour shall we Sally Ride
has four massive diesel generators that
provide electricity to both power and
propel the ship but it's oddly quiet
that's thanks largely to specially
designed propellers it's the quietest
ship that any of our crew have ever
sailed on and one of the reasons that's
very important is that a lot of the
things that we do in the ocean depend on
being able to measure sound that means
scientists can better listen for life
and even earthquakes in the deep the
ship is loaded with all sorts of sensors
that will allow scientists to measure
things like salinity and collect tiny
plankton
they'll also precisely monitor
fluctuations in ocean temperature
consider that 90 percent of the heat
associated with global warming is in the
ocean how that's distributed in the
ocean and the impact on the ocean and
its circulation and everything that
lives in the ocean is one of the major
questions of oceanography today because
the Sally Ride has to work in exact
locations and often rough seas she'll
actually adjust her position on her own
so we have the latest of what's called
dynamic positioning we can hold the ship
to the same spot on the globe with
respect to the the best GPS that's
available we can hold the ship in place
on the sphere of the earth to one meter
to retrieve their devices scientists
will deploy a huge crane this thing is
fancy it can automatically let out and
reel in line as the ship Bob's in rough
seas sadly though the Sally bride can't
do anything about that seasickness of
yours so bring the Dramamine